this is a real rumor that's out there
that you are being considered for the
part of the new James Bond Oh and that
sees a roommate back there
honestly I mean I don't want to you know
I hear it around obviously the the
silence is deafening and it sort of by
implication I'm like I get a night
people start they whisper as I walk by
I'm a cop on stuff probably yeah and I
just think you know were I to do what I
would do it differently a little bit
we're gonna do a different take on James
Bond yeah I mean I would still do that
I'd wear the tuxedos and I go into the
casinos and and you know with the girl
on the arm and the whole bit and I'd do
all that stuff but then you know if
there was some trouble or whatever's bad
guys I'd have a couple other dudes who
I'd hire I'd be like go get him wait
you're bond would be like go take care
of that yeah I'm staying here at the
casino i delegate cos all delegating
this these days you know what I mean you
got to look at time management
so I'm Bond and what's he do best look
good and chill out in a casino right
fighting that's gonna cut into that yeah
so what are you doing while your friends
your the people you prior for me they
run everywhere friendly employees they
well they're hunting down the the
villain what are you doing yeah I might
be getting a mani-pedi oh you gotta take
care of your you know Amina
you want to look good yeah yeah I might
just be lounging by the pool
cool yeah thanks man hey you seem super
into it no one eats almond I think you
could be a great bond thank you I think
there's a very good chance
I was gonna say I hate reddit you are
not British that is the big catch you're
not British well uh I am Canadian
so so the Queen is still my patron you
know quit that's right
that's like diet British yeah look oh
it's true yeah uh it's like British zero
yeah yeah wait I just put myself down
yeah yeah I would be I'd be great if I
could maybe I could get knighted though
yeah and I don't want obviously I wanted
to start lobbying for that now all right
but it'd be great to get a K okay well
it's out there it's in the ether and we
should start like a letter-writing cat
oh no that's the look no one writes
letters anymore uh let's move on to the
next topic you're not getting knighted
you